every year about 100,000 visitors head
to a remote location known as the end of
the world
it's Torres del Paine National Park in
Chile's Patagonia region here
adventurers find bliss amongst the
dramatic terrain that includes glaciers
fjords and mountains the centrepiece of
the park are the three granite towers
that stand tall over the otherwise flat
Patagonian play throughout the park the
towers beckon encouraging visitors to
take a closer look the eleven point two
mile mirador las torres hike is the
ultimate way to see these iconic rock
features but get ready getting to this
remote destination is quite the journey
fly into Chile's Punta Arenas Airport at
the tip of South America
it's the closest major airport to the
park but is still about five hours and
two bus rides away your first bus is to
the tourist hub of puerto natales which
is three hours to the north
buses run daily between punta arenas and
puerto natales and cost about 7,000
chilean pesos or about 10 US dollars
each way spend a night or two in puerto
natales and rest up you'll need all the
energy you can muster for this demanding
hike in patagonia weather is everything
if the weather's not right you may not
even get to see the towers through the
clouds so if you have flexibility in
your schedule wait till the weather's
clear when the big day arrives take the
7:30 a.m. bus to torres del pi one-way
fare is approximately 12 US dollars two
and a half hours later you will be ready
for your epic hiking adventure all
visitors must pay a park fee in cash of
approximately 32 US dollars you won't
have to camp to do this hike but it is
included in the park fee if it's
something you'd like to do be sure to
book your campsite in advance
once in the park you could walk from the
laguna amarga gate to the trailhead at
the hotel las torres another option is
to take a shuttle about four miles to
the start of the trail for approximately
five US dollars
the Mirador les torres trailhead is
clearly marked near the hotel and begins
as a deceptively flat path that quickly
turned steep as you pass over a couple
hanging bridges which makes for a great
photo-op the demanding hike is eleven
point two miles roundtrip and it
typically takes about seven to eight
hours to complete the steep uphill is
followed by a steep downhill which then
becomes another steep uphill through the
finish and that last mile it is yet
another brutally steep scramble and will
most likely test your limits but it
makes arriving at the base of the towers
even more rewarding enjoy marveling at
the parks namesake torres and capturing
some NatGeo worthy photographs before
beginning your trek back to reality
consider doing this trek with National
Geographic expeditions
[Music]